hello and welcome to this video playing
mobile yes call 95 we've got in London
okay at least he pushes t5 so the the it
will it won't be completely yeah not not
so London ish let's say it's a little
bit more non symmetrical okay cause f3
yeah thank you six should be played
attacking the pawn before is very likely
the answer however I just recognized
that if I take on d5 then it goes d6
okay let's not think about it too long I
was led that it was a five so okay but
it's um it's like well is that crying
over spilt milk or something yeah it's
um it's already gone this this moment so
let's see yeah I don't think II five is
a threat
he's five night-night age five even yeah
I was thinking 95 at night age five
season stronger okay and if he goes
night mm-hmm
why is that working night age five don't
know why this should work
okay I'm 95 95 Bishop g3 yeah well this
is just good okay now there's a couple
of things that are strong f6 for example
looks extremely strong I mean if he
takes it Queen takes I attack the the
bishop and queen takes b2 which would
win the full rock in the corner so this
kind of stuff pushing d6 and e5 is one
of the things that is either going to be
brilliant for the side who gets it in
because yet the opponent will be
completely completely and they are boxed
in what will be terrible and this is one
of the the terrible situations okay
Bishop to b5 so Knight f4 Bishop c6 I
can then desperado the thing on g2 if I
like it doesn't even do it okay so I
will take him
so I want two pawns both of them both
them pawn said he pushed got lost at the
end okay how do we do that
quit you have six probably I would like
to trap the Queen but it's not not that
easy you know in any case maybe I
shouldn't have canceled long actually I
mean I could have could cancel very
safely short and then push d5 and
everything okay it is a fairly I'm a
little bit exposed down
I went to
repositioned us a little bit really not
happy with my long castle that was that
was really unnecessary
could have just really castle shorter I
got no problem at all at least I didn't
see any problem I'm happy that yeah this
takes a bit of time there so I'm a head
on the clock
that's odd why is he not playing weird
yeah okay me is a lost position but why
now
okay this was so interesting for the
opening phase so this this be 545 255 is
an interesting line after a four I can
also play B should be seven I think but
becoming this is basically lost now what
it's not lost we have a we have some
tactics going on let's put it that way
as he for as a move which saves this one
but then I can take here for this and
then go is six which is fairly
complicated but I think before is fine
just advanced upon and f3 was
interesting is six I'm not sure about
this with hindsight and now und six
which i think is not a good such as not
a good move what I recognize is that
here there is a five but now that I
think of it this is not an issue because
I have always this move him okay the
engine actually wants me to play Knight
f4 yes but I mean I always have knight
c6 in general to stop the rook from
dropping off a d6 I just played knight
c6 quite quickly but Knight h5 seems to
be better already
you know it's not it's good to get this
immediate Liam and that's Queen h4 so
like here then you play this yeah this
is even better than than the game the
game was was okay but it's not like I'm
much better I just played those moves
quite quickly but now II 5 5 5 is bad
yeah Knight h5 all 95 is both good Queen
d2 and then taking
Oh Bishop d6 Bishop d6 is a cool move
yeah as Queen takes Knight X is good and
here there is the screen f6 idea that I
mentioned I don't think my move was bad
right it's a good advantage but this is
this is also strong and then here to
pick up the phone I mean he's got no
development move pawns all the time yeah
I have six and yeah this is basically
just the huge advantage if it takes here
I can desperado on g2 and have a huge
advantage as well and here probably
should punish him harder this like with
hindsight I rather would like to cancel
short in this position like him and just
short cancels this is easier to play I
think okay this is saying but I have
this I'm too sent two pawns up and have
two bishops oh it was just like this is
potentially a bit less safe than the
king would be under on the King side
probably okay guys thanks for watching